du bist ja was stellte vor wie hier
steckt wie so verkürzt die blöde sache
als offizielles update ressorts blöd und
das mache auch der lehrer seit das
wetter nicht seitdem hier mal was du
musst man ein problem vor der schule
schüler weil das objekt behandelt und
nicht als subjekt es könnte gar nicht
wenn ein lehrer mit 21 kindisch der
hammer gegriffen sind sie wirklich der
überzeugung dass seine spur aufspielen
gro szlig oder natur schafft spiele ich
lerne ich spannende gesellschaft wird
spielen reichlich belächelt und das
heißt vielfach die city dreimal
beschaffen und lehrern als immer nur
spielen
aber das passiert so viel unsichtbar
kann lernen ein spiel sein und warum
denken eltern dass die schule ihre
kinder tun und aggressiv macht davon
handelt diese fehlen
malin ist zehn jahre alt wenn andere
kinder zur schule gehen spielt er
schlagzeug für ihn und seine eltern ist
schlagzeug spielen genauso wertvoll wie
mathe oder deutsch lernen
gantenbein sie es auch sind so genannte
als cooler als kulisse für ihre kinder
nicht zur schule
die kinder lernen zu hause das was sie
interessiert wann immer sie bereit sind
dafür
[Musik]
das zeigt ein kind die funktioniert
nicht nach litauen
sie funktioniert nach einer interesse
nach jener intrinsischen bedürfnis und
welche bedürfnisse es unabhängig davon
ob das jetzt der gesellschaft im moment
sinn macht oder nicht
aber es interessiert sie und sind gar
nicht anders aus welche die elfjährige
olivia chinesisch einfach weil sie es
lernen will
so hat sie mit fünf auch schon englisch
und französisch gelernt die schule so
denken an school würde diesen vom kind
gesteuerten prozess noch stühlen kleben
wenn man nur knapp baby und westlich und
wird das land laut verrät aber gar nicht
machen
ich muss dafür dass sie wenn
erfindungen ist wenn jemand wo mit ihm
reden ist das sehr gefährlich aber es
rund alles wenn die richtig angekommen
ist und da ist ist so bewusst wurde dass
man da nicht einfach wenn du
unterbrechen
der lernprozess bei manz cooling werden
keinerlei schulische strukturen
nachgeahmt keine fixen unterrichtszeiten
kein vorgegebenes stoff die kinder sind
absolut frei und lernen offenbar
trotzdem oder vielleicht gerade deswegen
die 15-jährige sarah schreibt seit
einigen wochen an ihrem eigenen roman
schaue auf und auch starre fast
vorschlag als ich sehen will heran
gelaufen bin es ist noch so schräg
wir schauen uns beide entsetzt an was
machst du denn da schließlich hervor und
auch sicher ob nicht getan
doch das recht dass nazis dann tränen
aufgelöst ist sich los und weint du
meine güte nazis was ist denn passiert
kann gehen wir in die garderobe dann
kannst du dich setzen sagte ich zu ihr
ich glaube da hätte mit dass sie für
ihre sehr viel gespielt gespielt
gespielt und nun mal gespielt und zwar
gelang rolle spielen variationen und sie
hätte geschichte erfundene geschichte
nachspiel geschichte verarbeitet wo sie
selber belastet und es wieder so eine
möglichkeit vom spielen ist schön wenn
wir den prozess vom spieler unterbrochen
hatte
ich habe wisse nicht ob der ezb-stab
finde dass sie sogar schrieb von stoffen
die dem roman ich heiße rafina und was
hast du vier charaktereigenschaften
dienstag noch fließe konzentriert bühne
beliebt hilfsbereit und kommt die cs
sensibel herzens geldpolitik so bist du
ja
das schulzimmer der ganzen baines ist
das lebens was in der schule mensch und
umwelt oder mathematik heißt läuft bei
gantenbein es zum beispiel unter
mittagessen kochen 2009 unter zeitraum
für mathematik pur
die hände bis denn der wagen und wisse
genau wie viel sind die 2100 zeitraum
wie viele die sich auch als colin poole
david so viel gelernt über würmer
schnecken im garten und den taucher
zimmerer die themen er im moment nie als
mensch und umwelt thema vorbereitet will
die entstanden sind sehr viel aufwand
die mathematik flucht und von einigen
zieht seit 27 modellieren und zwar die
ganze schuljahr will findet im internet
statt fünfmal mit der ersten sechs
schuljahre mit dem stoff wahrscheinlich
eine halbes jahr haben vermutet und die
gesetze macht gerade mit und sind monika
bist einfach die ganze technik klinik
sie sind wegen seines liberalen
schulgesetzes ist der kanton appenzell
ausserrhoden ein eldorado für familien
die ihre kinder nicht zur schule
schicken wollen wäre eine bewilligung
für den sogenannten häuslichen
unterricht erhalten will muss aber auch
hier eine vielzahl von auflagen erfüllen
einmal im jahr beispielsweise müssen
alle kinder zu einem leistungstest an
tragen dem sogenannten cockpit test
wirklich schluss ist jetzt die daumen
dass man eigentlich stand dass es
überhaupt in 3d sommer gesagt kann mir
stinkts irgendwohin wo die neuen aktien
müsse müssen das machen wollen und
dennoch auch gesagt ja da war plötzlich
pistor dafür was kann immer nur gerade
thema das ich mit sätzen wie
spielerische schriftlichen
multiplikation styler und dann hamilton
urlaub mit blei und es sind in
verschiedene themen und endlich mehr
längen auf insgesamt vier bestellte
vorleistungsprodukten es gibt viele
familien die ihre kinder zu hause
unterrichten weil sich die schule nicht
mit ihren religiösen überzeugungen
verträgt gantenbein sie nicht gläubig
ihre spirituellen und philosophischen
überzeugungen fließen aber auch hier in
den familienalltag 1
so leben die ganzen bands beispielsweise
weitgehend wegen diverser frei werden
und und im frieden und ich so mache sie
das ja und natürlich kommt wieder so
früh es in dem er eigentlich ist es
ideal sind wird umsätzen im alltag und
in dem er sich messen ritual machten
sich ein das immer bewusst
bruno gantenbein ist angestellter
unternehmensberater an einer tagung von
projektmanagern stellte sein
unkonventionelles familien und
bildungsmodell vor manager floh
da geht es auch werke stellen manager
jörg networkers immer der gesamtprozess
im fokus haben das ist bei uns auch so
wir gestalten die umgebung immer
aufgrund der authentischen bedürfnisse
der kinder
und dann hat die mutter nicht da eine
herdprämie und ist einfach hausfrau dies
managerin und ist ganz subtil schaut sie
wie das geschieht mit den kindern
denkst du das ist immer so sein dass das
was die rolle der erziehung und das
urvertrauen sachen der frau
ich verstehe ja vorher also das erste
jahrhundert
die mutter hatte frau sozialisierung im
moment läuft natürlich ganz anders tun
mit den kitas und krippen und eben
vorher prämie und despektierliche und
und mit merkt der sco hochgradige
kernkompetenz von einer frau einfach
brach werde laut und der 90 frauen führt
über lecker war für kompetenz dass sie
da und haben die pflicht die hände
ganz ein stück vom leben und ich will
jetzt das führt frau sehr sehr positiv
negativ
die haiti ums thema bezahlt akkus schade
dass ich so dass wir muss ich entscheide
kinser so hat auch du riskanten bayern
ihren lehrerinnen beruf an den nagel
gehängt um ihren kindern rund um die uhr
nutzer lernt begleiterin vorbild und
freundin zu sein
als clark soziale kontakt aber mir sind
ein kaum überzeugt kinder brauchen
köchelnde buch genau hinter brauche die
erster linie eine gute begleitung
nächsten bezugspersonen und sie brauchen
da war sie liebe und respekt das ist da
wo sie wirklich brauchen kinder aber sie
bringt ja das ist ja auch schon probleme
mit der schule oder weil man auf dem
schulhausplatz florida das recht
gestellten funktionieren dort spannendes
thema das dritte eine vor der ersten
frage stellen und zeigt war ich damit
die sozialisierung und wenn wir dann
bitte redet von dir und wenn ihr aber
münster nicht auf die harte realität
vorbereitet werde schon in der schule
und dem fragen möchten das treffen mit
mobbing leistungsdruck rechtes stärken
und so weiter und den frack
amerikanischen das tier sozialisierung
wollen sich für die kinder wünscht
seit knapp zwei jahren trainieren olivia
und sarah neben dem lernen beinahe
täglich und ziehe erfolgreich
eiskunstlauf
das passt wirklich hin und vornehmlich
zum als cool im geist will natürlich
gleich tv dienen ist klar wird er
unterschiedlich sie winterkinder also da
ist wirklich jeden ganz großer wunsch
dass die fcc für das event für sicher
und vor dem halt ein ganz gut behindert
stadt das jetzt dass er so machen
überhaupt sondern dass selbst der nur
das zu was ich so mit denen michael wo
sitzt dort trainiert da hängt es
wirklich sehr gut und es ist es uns geht
auch andere moment bester sie war sofort
ein thema eifersucht und kommt und da
sind sich sitzt nicht so gewöhnt von der
heimat will es das eigentlich nicht aber
sie lernen auch mit dem ganz locker und
das hat einfach nervig rund merken dass
irgendwie sind die augen geschaut
amtlichen überhaupt also gar nicht sie
sind weltoffen wie gesagt alles als ich
überhaupt nicht der unterschied im
gegenteil das gefühl aber das ist der
charakter rasch in ihre mails gilt als
sozialer sind mit einer anderen sie
hatten von sicht hälfte gehe der anderen
als dass die hälfte mehr wird flavia ist
die beste freundin von sarah und olivia
sie besucht die achte klasse der
volksschule die prüfung so ist das nicht
gefallen andere karte ist eine
kroatische die anderes lacht ja ich das
ja glaub schon werden ausgelacht wenn es
eine schlechte note
[Musik]
regelmäßig trifft sich familie
gantenbein mit anderen ans kunden und
erfahrungen auszutauschen und sich von
neuen erlebnissen inspirieren zu lassen
zum beispiel auf dem toggenburger klang
league das war ein ganz cooler unterwegs
wenn wir also machen sie sich nicht so
nicht so einfach sie nach und wenn es
wahr grund bestätigung offenberg das
andere ja eigentlich unabhängig von
jeglicher gedankengängen die gleiche
grundbedürfnis und die liefern so
strömen
es sind vielleicht 50 familien die in
der schweiz als cooling betreiben
eine davon sind jonas aus urnäsch
claudia roller war früher ebenfalls
lehrerin
ich weiß nur nicht unterrichtet als
zweitklassiger kind kam mit strahlender
erfreut und an die zwei klassen
man hat das land viel spannender wirst
du deine garnitur co ich hatte überhaupt
keine zeit mehr für alles was die da
machen immer so ich bin mein sofa
rüsselsheim und also für die hand auf
ihr viel gemacht die handwerklich
saubere zocker also ab dem jahrgang
geriet und lisa zum lernen einfach gern
das war was ich jetzt wort lernen
ich weiß es nicht
lange schon ihr fast gefehlt denn ganz
schneller vorwärts
aber es ist ja chance während alle
lehrmittel daheim apps und ihr heimlich
jeder zieht matic schwach schrieb ich
alles ziel machen erklärt berger habe
ich schon basala geschäft und man lagert
nach zwölf mal zu eröffnen sie wohnen in
einem kinder aus sorgen konnten bei 1
alles hier ist auf die bedürfnisse der
kinder ausgerichtet
in der mautstation können sie ihre
gefühle ausdrücken ohne dass die
resultate bewertet werden oder noch
deren bedeutung gefragt wird bei
gantenbein dreht sich alles um die
kinder
ich begleite sie helfen wenn sie
irgendwie hilfe braucht wenn die farbe
schleifgerät kapuze war schnell wie die
pinsel läuft das fahrerfeld ist also
sind wir ziemlich schnell
ich bin also editieren in der rolle
seit mir zu und wäre ich auch für mich
schön einfach dafür zu entschuldigen und
teils und freue mich diese jungs knüpft
vor wenn sie doch immer raum zur die
jünger sind oder wo frauen und anhand
abputzen und schauen sie dass ihre
maschinen bis 18 uhr kinder obwohl es
das schon selber können die aber es gab
einfach den und beziehe katrin zu mir
kommt und sagt wünsch mir bietet schuhe
und dann bin ich das will ich weiß es
geht nicht um spin.de sondern es braucht
einfach jetzt gerade das moment liebe
zählt einfach zum server machen
ich weiß dass es fängt
unterwegs zu mir machen will sie
eigentlich schneller denselben grad und
hat mir flügel eingebüßt
es ist ganz spannend da wirklich so viel
gefragt aber es ist so wenn ich sehe wie
die erfüllt sind das erfüllt mich selten
auf ich habe nicht eine sekunde das
gefühl dass nämlich bisher gantenbein
sagen von sich sie praktizieren als
cooling nicht sie seien als cooling und
das heißt für sie weit mehr als die
kinder nicht zur schule zu schicken als
cooling ist ein lebensentwurf der aus
kindern bessere erwachsene und die welt
schlussendlich zu einem besseren ort
machen soll
es braucht ganz viel älteren auto mit
dass ältere die einzigartigkeit ab ihre
kinder war das ist nicht schön für jene
jahre alles kaputt gemacht wird oder
sagt man mal vieles kaputt gemacht wird
und dann hat mir andré lüth andere sind
wo groß werde tvo mit anderen augen die
welt wo man nicht dem mainstream und
reflektiert mit schwimmen also mehrere
zelte wohin australien genau auf die
kirche gedanken oder in deutschland oder
in england auch in amerika also in dem
sinne ist es nötig sie erfinden sondern
mir einfach der offenen entdecken die
sinne und die gang der froh ist dass das
sogar ein natürlicher prozess ist das
dass der mensch immer mehr potenzial
wird wird für holen und und erkennt das
potenzial im verhalten eigentlich zur
künftig irgendwer letztlich der völlig
unter
[Musik]
nein